Alyssa Milano is taking a stand
she's taking a stand against Fascism and
hate and white supremacy she's giving
back her Tesla here's what Alyssa Milano
said she said
I gave back my Tesla I bought the VW
electric vehicle I love it I'm not sure
how advertisers can buy space on Twitter
publicly traded companies products being
pushed in alignment with hate and white
supremacy does not seem to be a winning
business model
I don't know if Alyssa Milano is a huge
history buff but uh
VW has a little bit more of a sorted
history than Tesla does a VW of course
was founded by Adolf Hitler himself and
the Nazi party uh it means the people's
wagon Volkswagen
uh but of course she doesn't know this
she doesn't know anything
this
reminds me that people very prominent
people in public life have absolutely no
historical frame of reference or memory
okay everything is just in this
Perpetual now this Perpetual sort of
mania that we're in and so people forget
forget about ancient history or medieval
history Hitler founded Volkswagen less
than 100 years ago
doesn't matter there's just this
Perpetual now and you're seeing this
accelerate you're seeing this accelerate
in Canada
actually Justin Trudeau I referenced
this a little bit last week Justin
Trudeau is now the first world leader to
go on a drag race show
hi Queen hi I'm so sorry to interrupt I
know it's a big day but seeing as we
have the best Queens from around the
world we thought you deserved a proper
welcome please help me welcome to the
Canada's drag race work room the prime
minister of Canada Justin Trudeau
all right
do I have the curtsy do I have to kiss
his ring I heard you had a summit and I
think I'm a little too late yeah
unfortunately we're actually just about
to do makeover episodes
anybody want to take it on
this is groundbreaking the first ever
world leader to visit a drag race set uh
I'm glad to be the first I look forward
to the time there's a third or a fourth
to have a world leader in the work room
talking to us how amazing is that you
better work Justin Trudeau yes
totally historic isn't this so historic
but then when I saw the clip I thought
wait a second
didn't Nancy Pelosi already go on one of
these shows wait a second didn't AOC
already go on one of these shows
oh but I guess neither of them are world
leaders in the sense that neither of
them are a head of state
so now Justin Trudeau he's making
history it's all it's how historical is
this Justin Trudeau is the third lib in
the last six months to go on a weird
drag queen show
but it's historic because he's the first
world leader from Canada on this special
version of the show
how many
historic firsts
do there have to be
before
people recognize that the alleged
historical first groups have a ton of
power and dominance in our society how
many how many do we see with because
the way this is Being Framed is this is
so brave of Justin Trudeau no not at all
it would be brave not to go on the drag
queen show the the people who are in
power
are relentlessly pushing transgenderism
it's it would it would take some courage
to stand up against that but it's very
effective if you want to amass power one
very effective way to do it is to claim
victimhood the reason we have to fight
against the great reset agenda of just
putting us all in our pods and we don't
see anybody and we're just isolated
we're spending all this time alone is
that when people are broken down into
this atomized individual we're all
isolated it's much easier to control us
it's much easier to transform Society we
are seeing it happen in real time I had
you a viral Tick Tock video
do you think it's good for kids to see
all of these sexualized things like
people kissing each other girls kissing
each other guys and thongs girls out
yourself yes because if you don't show
them this now then they Harbor who they
are as they get older they feel like
they're not included in society so you
think sexualized activity should begin
with them at a young age yes I mean I
was watching like eight years old and
you think that's good yeah should the
LGBT be inclusive of bestiality I don't
even know what that is with animals
is that that yeah now I know that this
is just an anecdote I know this this is
just one lady on Tick Tock but the
plural of anecdote is data
and you see people making these sorts of
arguments all the time and frankly she's
got a point
he goes yeah if we're going to
if we're going to tell people that it's
cool to do all this eccentric sexual
stuff when they're adults then we got to
normalize it when they're kids they got
to see that they got to see that
represented
and yeah maybe that maybe it seems kind
of creepy like we're sexualizing kids
and yeah maybe I'm gonna advocate for
bestiality and things but you know okay
whatever Love Is Love right
this is happening
conservatives are warning that you know
by the time we get down the slippery
slope pretty soon they're going to
normalize weird child sex stuff they are
doing that that is already happening
conservatives are so good at predicting
terrible things that have already
happened it's like pretty soon we're
gonna we're gonna start seeing the
things that already we started seeing
two years ago
and I don't want to hear that this is
some crazy conspiracy theory okay
in the post Jeffrey Epstein world
I never want to hear about crazy
conspiracy theories creepypeto island is
real we know about creepypeto Island
and we know that creepypeto Island
involved some of the most prominent
wealthy powerful people on planet Earth
so I don't want to hear about it you saw
that Balenciaga ad
that bizarre Balenciaga act we covered
last week where it was little kids kind
of frowning holding up a like a
dominatrix like a s m kind of clad teddy
bear
and conservatives pointed out this is
really weird and actually one of the
Balenciaga products was was on top of a
Supreme Court case about child
pornography
and
then what happened there was an outcry
and valenciaga pulled it down and said
we're looking into legal uh recourse
against the people who put this set
together so even now the Liberals want
to brush us under the rug but Balenciaga
itself acknowledged this is sick this is
bad we got caught but this is weird
what's going on with this child's sex
stuff
Kim Kardashian who does a lot of work
with Balenciaga she came out she said
this is really disturbing but it's
happening okay
someone gave the okay on the set someone
gave the okay on the photos someone gave
the okay
putting it on the website
we know apparently American intelligence
knew about creepypeto Island because
when
Acosta Alex Acosta not the terrible CNN
talking head but Alex Acosta who was up
for labor secretary under Trump and he
was U.S attorney before that he was U.S
attorney Prosecuting Jeffrey Epstein
when he went after Jeffrey Epstein in
his own words apparently he was told no
no forget about Epstein he belongs to
intelligence so we know that this is
happening with the ascent of lots and
lots of people
[Music]
thank you